like you're making the argument like
this isn't just hospitality or movie
theaters this could be kind of across
industries depending where you are and
what your balance sheet looks like you
could be disappearances you're bringing
up some really good examples so let's
follow those examples let's trace
throughout those right this is a key
word traceroute [ __ ] follow the
betrayal of breadcrumbs we have this is
now the time we're honestly like the the
propensity to action should be avoided
at all costs like this is where you sit
down you tape your hands to your hips
your lap you don't touch the [ __ ]
keyboard and you just learn and you
study you know you're not supposed to be
day trading in moments like this you're
supposed to be learning but let's take
your examples so you know the the the
major movie studios were forced
essentially to go day and date now the
problem with that is that you can't put
that genie back in the bottle and the
other problem with it is that they may
have gotten the pricing wrong they have
no time they had no time to really do a
pricing elasticity and release these
movies for $100 a ticket on iTunes
they've released them for $20 and so
it's going to be very difficult for
Disney and you know Universal and Warner
Brothers and Sony Pictures so all of a
sudden come back and say hey we're gonna
try to give the movie theaters back
their window of exclusivity I think
that's that that's basically very
difficult if not impossible and then the
second thing that's going to happen is
that they're not going to have the same
pricing power that they would have had
with the online distributors now all of
that has one really important
implication which is the cost of the
movies that they make are gonna willing
to change and then as a result the cost
of what they're willing to pay is going
to change as a result the cost of what
they pay they're unionized employees is
gonna change what the CGI maker you know
charges changes what the caterer charges
changes and so this is why in when you
have these big sort of cataclysmic
economic events what you have is a
period that's very deflationary right
you have a period where prices fall and
fall and fall now in the Great
Depression the only way that we could
buck that trend is to basically get rid
of the gold standard you know in 33 I
think it was and so we're gonna have to
have some version of that which is to
basically create a bottom on pricing and
to create a bottom on price ability so
the movie theaters more than likely go
BK and in that if you were a read or if
you were a tenant or if you own the land
you're gonna have to figure out how to
repurpose that how to try to pay your
debt obligations otherwise you're gonna
go bankrupt or you're gonna go default
or you're just gonna hand the keys over
to those facilities to banks at which
point you know probably the beneficiary
is Amazon or some other sort of like
physical retail that needs last-mile
distribution and some of these movie
theaters represent the right size and
the right physical location okay so
that's that's one then you talked about
startups that's another great example
you know for a long time I think in 2015
or 16 I started to become very bearish
on enterprise software and the reason
was because we shifted much more towards
SMB than we did towards mid market and
enterprise and the reason was because
the money cycle was faster it was you
could put small amounts of dollars to
work the companies would sell online via
credit card to other SMBs who would buy
very quickly you would show revenue
traction and then you were able to use
that to then go and raise an up round so
venture capitalists loved it the
entrepreneurs loved it they used it to
attract employees because the equity
looked like they was accreting very
quickly but then you realize how brittle
your customer base is in a moment like
this because they are the first to stop
paying they are the first to not honor
their contracts they're the first to go
out of business unfortunately because
they don't have the cash cushion and so
there's going to be unfortunately a lot
of carnage in the SMB space that there
won't be in the enterprise space so now
go back to a company like word day or
you know ServiceNow or sa P or some
young startups that have explicitly
chosen to sell into the global 1,000
netskope is one as an example that sells
security software into the global 1000
they consumed enormous amounts of
capital to build their go to market but
in many ways
is that capital becomes a protective
moat that will keep them safe in a
moment like this because their customers
have a higher probability of staying in
business now their business may slow
down their business may get rear ated
but their business isn't going out of
business
but if you were selling mostly to SMEs
there's a very good chance that 50% of
your revenue is impaired and at that
point again if you're already money
losing which most of these startups were
selling to SMBs at price points that
didn't make sense because you were
trying to get out of a J curve it's
going to be next to impossible the other
strategy that startups also employed was
being mono product right it was not only
go to SMB charge something small if
anything at all but do it for one single
point solution create a wedge and then
expand well again you go back to this
problem that when companies are
rebuilding their expense base what
they're doing is making decisions about
what costs to bear the company that has
a mono product solution is last in line
to be considered because it doesn't
solve enough of the CEO CFO CIOs
problems so then all of a sudden you
start to make substandard decisions
meaning you'll take Microsoft because
it's a whole stack of things it's one
person it's one sale they can now
discount and you have this increasing
returns of scale property that that
benefits Microsoft disproportionately
right so you have to be very unique you
have to be a zoom or a slack or octa in
that environment to be able to defend
yourself adequately so that's also a
very problematic dynamic amano product
company is going to be very challenged a
SMB focus go to market sales strategy is
very challenged so to your point like
the examples of contraction I think are
numerous the examples of green shoots
exist but they're harder to find and to
be quite honest they're speculative
because they're they're not about
adoption they're now more about
valuation like everybody loves zoom
everybody loves lock it
it's fabulous you have to be able to
write size valuation in moments like
this as well